[Music]
what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know in csgo
there are a few things more satisfying
than a good off kill whether it's a 200
IQ wallbang a dirty noscope or a cyclic
I feel like I could wash these
highlights all day so you know what
let's go ahead and do just that with the
top 10 off kills in csgo coming in at
number 10 is Stewie to Kay's epic 3k to
force ot in the final map of the eally
Boston major grand finals
[Applause]
we call these number they came back all
the way
[Applause]
there are many different ways an op can
be affected but the difference between
average and amazing plays lies right
here at number nine as do three hits an
insane to man collateral through the
smoke
[Applause]
body comes in at number eight on our
list as he displays his creative
abilities with the now-infamous
body wallbang after pulling it off in
back-to-back rounds against astralis
body not only shocked viewers at home
but also French and American casters on
stream device no work short that's that
still 10 - like you said a difficult
considering Foley's trying it again no
you can't possibly do that twice at all
but that's not where it ends
body went on to recreate the same kill
in another match versus mousesports
leaving the crowd chanting his name
arguably one of the best players I'm a
Satoshi using the the fabled body wall
bang he's gonna go ahead and show us
that here and it does work out Chris J
is gonna be kicking himself it's just
beautiful and the crowd is just going
insane that was the everyone loved his
body number 7 goes to fanatics JW who
stood up and asserted his dominance
making sure all eyes were on him in an
effort to take B site with a minute left
on the clock
SK ran into the wrong man at the wrong
time
and I'm gonna be nating off and JW of
course lands the first shot they'll be
fully aware I'm like don't blink don't
flake because it's double hair as well
oh that's like one of the sickest rounds
known as one of the best offers to ever
play the game
Kenny s is no stranger to highlight reel
plays at number six
Kenny puts on an absolute clinic for the
crowd you know 1v3 clutch at dreamhack
London Gray's happy wasn't expecting
that bomb does get planted still okay
yes stuck in the sight finding this
guy's absolutely insane what are you
gonna do and that's happening a
three-on-one situation once again in
favor of easy skins and that is going in
one by one mole once again letting the
Pulido need to be pencil in the same
time ie need to be coming in the same
team the fact that he's got
opportunities to take three one-on-ones
is absolutely nuts one of the only
players in csgo to serve as both primary
operand in-game leader fallen shows us
why he is among the best of the best in
this to be five clutch in our number
five play take the Sean it's such a
perfect QT strategy there it's cold
Zahra didn't know what the hell is going
on with it
reacting pastors team girls coming in
ballin Ashley gets teased as well this
kill is it it's gonna be guarded now
it's time to fall back and he's fallen
gonna be capitalizing there as well as I
said you've won the round at that point
why are you giving your opal way but
still fallen battling on here it's gonna
be a three-on-one situation after such a
glorious play there from the CTS
10 seconds of one's gonna have a
wide-open site here that he could plan
towards baron guy hunt you can plan
towards bank and make this really
interesting you know 5 seconds he knows
it yeah it's gonna get that Bob down
right in the nick of time and Navi
you're gonna be sitting out quite
literally on the opposite side of the
map and he is just waving a flag saying
come and get me 17 points of health in a
dream this would be the ACE Kyle hutch
from full and I'm believing you're a bit
of a believer would you suggest that you
don't want to stop believing but why
don't you cast around okay
[Music]
we will forget because they go Zeus
saving the day for Navi but could you
stop no way at number 4 Guardian shows
us why he is one of the best players to
ever pick up the off with just 19
seconds left on the clock
Guardian puts on a one-man show as he
dances around pillar wiping out an
onslaught of no sports players coming
from all directions they come in AIDS
rain in here come the bodies as well got
in just put one down better believe he
can so so sick that shot is basically
what the hell is going on our number 3
play sees nifty go on an absolute tear
with three back worthy shots killing
three tyloo players during the second
map of the Boston major Asia Minor grand
final oh and each one of them was a wall
bang
but he will have another crack at a shot
and this time he does to live Oh nifty
is disgusting a lot with a bomb stroke
now as well on real plays purely yeah if
you can see the past and a site memory
will be right for the taking a small
crack that he can see it somebody's
landed four Scout shot now this round is
back I'm done
I am absolutely done I don't know that
I've ever seen someone do that not an
official match have you I mean I'm sure
someone is gonna tweet me like yeah look
at this clip from this tournament but
the fattest coming in at number two on
our list is simple who in a 1v2 against
fnatic with 30 seconds left drops down
from the heavens to noscope both Dennis
and Crim's to win the round this play
was so good that it earned simple a
graffiti tag on the map as a tribute to
this unforgettable moment couple smokes
in the same place
this is this is a major J simple it's an
assassin this kind a simple I don't know
man if it comes in with this mouth that
he had one button there was no blowing
past the competition at number one on
our list is none other than colds eras
legendary jumping off recognized as one
of the most iconic op kills in the game
coldzera puts a quick end to Team Liquid
B rush with a 4k that could only be
described as divine there's a lot of
pressure on him he's gotta hit these
shots we saw following this in his spot
before the same spot but but with much
more utility to work with here he comes
once again the first face is attorneys
gonna hit the ground there's cold
honesty with your play think of all
scenes there on the B apartments I have
no words to describe oh my holy okay
okay guys that was our list but if you
have a god like op kill that you think
we missed don't be afraid to flame us I
mean tell us in the comment section
below
thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]